karl llenó el tanque de su camión con
400 litros de gasolina y se preparó para
entregar un cargamento de plátanos en
alaska el camión consumió ocho décimas
partes de litros de gasolina por cada
kilómetro recorrido grafica la cantidad
de gasolina que queda en el tanque del
camión en litros como una función de la
distancia recorrida en kilómetros muy
bien así que aquí tenemos un plano
coordinado muy bien donde en el eje
horizontal tenemos la distancia
recorrida por el camión en kilómetros y
en el eje vertical tenemos la gasolina
restante medida en litros en el tanque
de nuestro camión o más bien del camión
de carlos verdad así que nosotros en
este ejercicio podemos jugar con los
puntos para definir esta línea porque
justamente dos puntos es lo que
necesitamos para definir una línea así
que nosotros necesitamos ver dos puntos
que se encuentren en esta línea veamos
si podemos deducir la gasolina del
camión parados
tintas distancias y así poder definir la
línea que representa a la gasolina en
función de los kilómetros recorridos ok
entonces que tal primero si vemos cuando
no nos hemos movido verdad qué pasaría
cuando el camión no se ha movido y de
hecho esto nos lo dicen en el enunciado
así que te invito a que hagas una pausa
y trates de verlo por tu propia cuenta
entonces el enunciado nos dice karl
lleno el tanque de su camión con 400
litros de gasolina y se preparó para
entregar un cargamento de plátanos en
alaska quiere decir que cuando ni
siquiera se había movido en realidad el
tanque estaba lleno con los 400 litros
de gasolina ahora como pensamos el
segundo punto así que como pensamos esto
bueno en realidad nos dice que el camión
consume 8 décimas partes de litros de
gasolina por cada kilómetro verdad y
vamos a hacer este digamos esta última
parte en nuestro cuaderno de notas muy
bien así que nosotros tenemos que el
camión consume ocho décimas partes de
litros de gasolina por cada kilómetro
recorrido vamos a hacer una tablita como
siempre lo hemos hecho nosotros podemos
poner de un lado la distancia en
kilómetros y del lado derecho de nuestra
tabla vamos a poner la cantidad de
gasolina aunque la gasolina por supuesto
esto medido en litro
y recordemos que es la gasolina verdad
como función de la distancia recorrida
pero no es la gasolina que queda en el
tanque que queda en el tanque no la que
hemos gastado y nosotros sabemos que
cuando hemos recorrido 0 kilómetros
tenemos 400 litros de gasolina tenemos
400 litros muy bien ahora por ejemplo
nosotros podemos ver en la gráfica que
el eje horizontal tiene marcas cada 100
kilómetros vamos a ver qué ocurre
justamente cuando hemos recorrido 100
kilómetros muy bien vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando hemos recorrido una distancia de
100 kilómetros bueno la gasolina que nos
queda será la siguiente bueno teníamos
400 litros 400 litros y vamos a dejar ya
este color para notar darnos tanto iu a
400 litros le tenemos que restar la
cantidad de gasolina que hemos gastado
en estos 100 kilómetros y eso es si
nosotros gastamos
ocho décimas partes de litros de
gasolina por cada kilómetro pues
tendríamos que multiplicar 188 décimas
partes del litro verdad nosotros
gastamos 8 décimas partes del litro por
cada kilómetro pero recorremos 100
kilómetros esto nos da la cantidad de
gasolina total que hemos gastado verdad
así que podemos ver que las unidades de
kilómetros se cancelan y simplemente nos
queda lo siguiente 400 litros
menos
ocho décimas partes por cien son ochenta
verdad 08 0.8 por 100 son 80 litros y
ahora tenemos 400 menos 80 litros que
esos son 320 litros entonces si nosotros
regresamos a este ejercicio
nosotros podemos mover este punto a la
distancia 100 kilómetros y subirlo hasta
320 que es lo que nos queda de gasolina
cuando hemos avanzado 100 kilómetros y
aquí podemos ver que cuando hemos
recorrido 500 kilómetros ya se nos agotó
la gasolina del tanque